and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak i will then invite you
at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones
therefore can i ask you that when
invited to speak you remember to turn
your microphone on and when you have
finished to turn it off
please reference reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
finally i draw your attention to the
notice on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and i advise that the fire exit is the
door behind this top table
good afternoon councillor thompson
thank you very much
meeting underground thank you council
but we we knew you were on your way so
uh no apologies necessary thanks
okay
so we go to item number two apologies
for absence
berna do we have any apologies for
absence
thank you chairman yes we've received
apologies for absence from councillors
duik and siddal and councillor swain is
substituting for cancer civil this
afternoon thank you thank you
number three the minutes
it is recommended chairman come the
minutes please show that i'm in
attendance please thank you council
morris uh berna can we please uh
are we talking about these minutes
yeah the minutes for this meeting thank
you stop correct councilman
thank you can we can we note that
councillor morris is in attendance
please
thank you chairman we always minute
councillors in attendance great thank
you very much
number three the minutes it is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 6th of september
2021 found on pages 3 to 8 are approved
as a true and accurate record
move do i have a seconder for that
motion
thank you councillor fleming thank you
very much
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of accuracy please do so
is there anybody
can we agree those minutes by a cent
agreed so those minutes are agreed thank
you berna
thank you chairman
so we moved to declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosure pecuniary interest other
bikini interest on non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they also
require to disclose any such interest as
soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
would anyone like to declare any
interest
so we have nobody so we have nobody
thank you burner
thank you
uh public participation i can advise
that we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
so that takes us to agenda item 5 found
on page 9 to 90 of the meeting pack
which is the report mr quelch can you
please present the report
uh thank you chairman uh well
you've got my report and my report has
two appendices that is the new
model code that's been produced by the
local government association and it's
the revised version of may of last year
i say revised version because
this one is the third revision
um
so
and this is the third and final one as
far as i know for the time being
you also will have
um a second appendix and that is the
guidance that's recently been issued on
how to interpret
uh the new code of conduct
um
as far as my report is concerned you'll
see i've set out the history of how
we've got where we've got to in terms of
this particular
new code of conduct
and it is the result of a recommendation
made by a government committee called
the committee on standards in public
life
and back in the beginning of 2019
they recommended that a new model code
of conduct should be produced for local
government the local government
association
took up uh the task and
this is the result what you have in your
hands in appendix one
now
it is fair to say that um there hasn't
been a total national take-up of all
local authorities
of this code there have been some
issues of clarity
about the code that have made
some councils a bit wary
and that is particularly the case with
the essex
authorities none of the essex
authorities so far
have adopted the code but that is about
to change
because
the revisions made
particularly the final one
on the 17th of may of last year
they satisfied pretty well all the
monitoring officers of all
the essex authorities we had a combined
meeting to discuss it so at least we
were working together
and i now know that
the county council plan to push forward
with adoption of the code and although
they haven't got a set date i know their
monitoring officer is thinking in terms
of june
and i believe most of the other district
councils
are
are either in the process of moving
towards adoption or will be doing so
shortly
um the only thing
i would like to say about the um
the new code itself i think it is
an improvement
on the code we now have
i think it builds on some of the really
important principles that have now been
established through that code and been
practiced by councillors throughout the
the country
and what it does is and you'll see in my
report i i mention a few things that i
think are good about the new
local
code
and that has been written in the first
person that makes it much easier to read
um
and also in the code i don't mention
this in my report but if you read the if
you read appendix one you'll see
also in the code itself there are
explanations whereas in the old code
there were none
so
it's it's much more self-explanatory and
of course the second really valuable
point is there is now guidance
um that's been produced by the lga on
how to interpret the code and it's full
of examples
and i personally think it's a really
good piece of guidance
so hopefully they'll be if members have
any doubt how to interpret the new model
code
those will be dealt with as members read
the guidance
in fact you can dispense of me you won't
need to come to me any longer you'll
just read the guidance and it'll all be
totally clear to you
um
perhaps a real significance to members
is this whole issue of declaration of
interests
and
as you know under the old code there are
three categories of interest there are
disclosable pecuniary interests which
are
are
are defined in statute in the localism
act
and if you don't declare those you not
only breach the code of conduct but you
also commit the crime
they're called disclosable pecuniary
interest then the other one is other
pecuniary interests which are just two
issues and they're very specific
relating to contractual relationships
between
the authority and the councillor
uh very rarely declared because they
often just don't that's rare that
actually
there are other
interests and the third one which causes
a lot of problems sometimes for
everybody is
what is a non-pecuniary interest
now um the one thing about non-pecuniary
interests is they only apply to the
member themselves
whereas
in relation to
the new
code
non-pecuniary interests
not only embrace spouse or partner
or cohabitee
but also
um relative or close associate
so that is really widened and i think
that was a really big weakness
under the
a weakness under the present code that
there could be an issue that related to
your brother or your sister
um you didn't have to declare that
um
as a non-pecuniary interest
but it might affect their well-being
for example
let's just say there was um
you're looking at a local development
policy uh the new plan
and
it was could potentially affect your
brother or your sister
or any other relative you wouldn't have
had to have declared that as a
non-pecuniary interest because it
doesn't relate to you
um you could argue what it does because
it's your well-being and how your sister
or brother is affects your well-being
but it wasn't explicit
it wasn't explicit
now this new code is explicit
that any interest that affects
your um
your relative or your close associate
you have to or close it so you have to
declare so under the new code
there are also three categories
um there is still disclosable pecuniary
interest because that's statutory
so that remains
and those are defined under the new code
in the table one
in appendix one
then there are
what are called other registerable
interests
um and those are those defined in table
two of appendix one
which are really to do with
unpaid directorships
um whether if you're a member of a
charity or a public body
or other body that's influencing public
opinion you have to register those and
at a meeting
if there is
a
direct
let me just find it let me just find the
new code because i'm still familiarizing
myself with it
um
yeah if there's a matter arising at the
meeting which directly
relates to the financial
interest or well-being of one of these
other registerable interests in table
two
then you'd have to declare that as well
and the third
category is
non-registrable interests
and you might say this is akin to the
non-pecuniary
one if you want but it's quite different
in many ways because it's broken down
into two types of interests you've got
financial interests that are
non-registerable and you've got
well-being interests
okay
and within that you have to ask yourself
does this particular
is this is this matter on the agenda
something that directly relates
to this
non-registerable interest
um
this financial interest or well-being
interest that could be not only you it
could be your partner or your spouse or
it could be a relative or a close
associate
and then there's a sec then you've got
to ask yourself the question
if it doesn't directly relate does it
affect
your financial interest or well-being or
that of your
partner or close
associate or relative
um
the reason is
in the first case
if it's a directly relatable issue
then you cannot debate the issue and you
cannot vote and that's the case for the
other two as well the dpi disclosure
opportunity interest and the other
registrable interest
if
those are engaged you cannot
vote
or discuss you have to leave the room
and so with the third non-registerable
interest if it's directly related
you likewise cannot vote you cannot
debate it and you must leave the room
now in the case of a non-registerable
interest that only affects
you your financial interest or
well-being you then have to go on and
ask
two other questions
does it affect it more than the
financial interests of the majority of
the inhabitants of the ward your ward
affected by the decision and if it does
would a reasonable member of the public
knowing all the facts consider that this
interest would affect your view of the
wider public interest now it all sounds
i made it sound rather complicated i
know
but actually as you start to digest it
all it isn't as complicated as it sounds
first of all so we've got three three
categories we've got the under the new
code the disclosable pecuniary interest
which is the same as under the existing
code
we have a new interest called other
registrable interests which relates to
as i said
public interest bodies
um um unpaid directorships
etc and then there is this third new
category of non-registerable interest
and you have to look at
whether they directly relate directly
relates is where
say you've got your sister again and
she's put in a planning application
that that that would
directly relate to her well-being and so
therefore directly relates to you
and then you have to ask if it doesn't
direct relate does it affect so
there might be someone that puts in a
licensing application near
to your house
now that doesn't directly relate to you
and it is a non-registerable interest
but it might affect your well-being your
enjoyment of your property
and then you'd have to go and ask
yourself the question does that affect
me more than the majority yes it does
and
would a reasonable a member of the
public knowing all the facts think it
would affect my view of the wider public
interest
and you probably conclude that joe
public would think that in which case
you then have to not only declare the
interest you neither could vote or
discuss the matter
so
and that's my brief run view all the
other things like bullying
like bringing the authority into
disrepute
like using your position for your own
advantage those remain the same i think
they're made a little bit clearer and
the explanations in the code i think are
helpful and of course you have the
advantage of this hot off the breast
guidance from the local government
association that i've already mentioned
which is in your appendix too
there is one thing
uh finally
that um
you may have picked it up
if you go to page appendix one and you
go to
page 11 of appendix one
um
and you will see
that there it that's the
disclosure of non-registerable interests
and
you will see
that paragraph nine
it reads
where a matter
referred to in paragraph eight that's a
non-registrable interest
effects
financial interest
or well-being
and to a greater extent than it affects
the financial interest of the majority
of the inhabitants of the ward affected
by the decision and then and
i personally think
that should read
to a greater extent than it affects the
financial interests
or well-being of the majority of the
inhabitants
because
paragraph nine starts where a matter
affects the financial interest or
well-being
of the particular councillor obviously
to a greater extent than it affects the
fine interest finally financial interest
of the majority of inhabitants etc etc
etc i think that's an omission
now the reason i think that is because
the guidance
indicates
that well-being
in making that assessment whether it
affects
you more than the majority of other
inhabitants that is involved as well as
just financial interests
so my view would be
that if you
if members are minded to recommend to
full council the the adoption
of this new code
that that should be added in
that particular
phrase or
well-being
under 9
a
now as to the recommendation itself
um
i
i put in something you might think is um
a little bit bold of me
um
asking you
asking are asking council
to give me a little bit more power
um in the sense that
we don't know when the other authorities
in essex are going to adopt the code and
one advantage of
um
if essex county council adopt the code
and all the districts don't
then there would be
those dual-hatted members who are both
county councillors and district councils
would then be operating to a different
code
by the way incident that's also the case
within our own district
if this district council
adopts the code but parishes don't and
they're not obliged to
they can stick with the old code then
those members that are district
councillors and parish councillors would
have the misfortune of operating
under
um two different codes which can be very
confusing
so there is an advantage i think in
this district council
if it if it goes for adopting the code
um
priming the
taking of effect of the code at the same
time as the county council so there
isn't a period where
dual hatted members are operating under
different codes
hence my suggestion that um
that you recommend to council that
that that there is the adoption of the
code of conduct
to take effect by so that there's the
backstop date first of november 2022
unless brought into effect prior by the
monitoring officer depending on when
essex county council bring into effect
the new code of conduct i hope that
makes sense
thank you yeah councillor maze
yeah thank you mr chairman um do we have
any idea as to when essex county council
are going to be debating this point
please
um
i i know the essex county council are
at this moment in the process of moving
towards that
um they obviously can't give a date as
because they haven't got through the
process yet of deciding whether to adopt
it but i i know they would like to do so
sometime in june if possible okay
thank you
so is that the report
thank you
yeah and that's it thank you very much
mr quelch um so
would we shall we go to this
recommendation and then open it up to
debate as it stands
i think
um
yeah i mean you you you yes you could
you could ask um but you could ask for a
a proposal and a second do the
recommendation and then obviously it's
debatable and then we will we then we
decide whether or not we wish to change
the record well you can do it like
planning application if you wanted to
where
i know the the the idea is you just um
debate the report and then you have a
motion well i i i think we'll go i think
we will go to this recommendation and
then we'll have the have the debate and
then
see what the end result is and then if
we change anything
we can vote on that
so um i shall go to the recommendation
and the recommendation is to counsel
that it adopts a model code of conduct
at appendix one version of may 2021
to take effect by the first of november
2022 unless brought into effect prior by
the monitoring officer depending on when
essex county council bring into effect
the new code of conduct
and i think what that means is
is that
by november
the 1st
2022 we will adopt this code of conduct
unless essex county council
bring their code of conduct forward this
model and then we will fall in line at
the same time is that correct
so that's that's that's the
recommendation so could i have um a
seconder thank you councillor helm
second vote thank you very much
councillor
um so now i shall
sorry council sorry
just a small clarification are we
assuming that the slight amendment that
can others count
mr quinn's suggested is included in that
um i was going to recommend this
recommendation and then let use decide
that and uh if that's the case we'll
change the recommendation
in that case can i propose
propose the amendment because you have
to deal with the amendment before the
right thank you very much
mr quelch's suggestion as an amendment
to this
thank you very much councillor thompson
and
thank you very much councillor helms so
we had that so um
thank you councillor bill
[Laughter]
one of the questions i did was why
wouldn't other councils
approve this and all come under one
umbrella so that you've got
standardization
which to me makes sense because
otherwise
you know it's going to get tacky
and
really i think to myself
if they're always the same singing for
the same song it makes a lot more sense
i'm thinking what what reasons would
they have been not adopted because it is
a lot clearer and it does tie down
certain issues
and highlight specific issues as well um
yeah i mean i don't know what's
happening
as it's an lta recommendation etc etc
mr coach yeah
yeah
um that thinking is it was exactly the
thinking that the lg had lga had in
producing
this
improved code
building on the good work of the
the old code
um
and their their thinking was we're going
to improve it everyone's going to go in
for it there'll be a sort of national
code but of course the localism act
gives discretion
to each local authority to adopt his own
code there are certain mandatory things
like the disclosable pecuniary interests
because
they're very serious
but anything else
is discretionary now i think the reason
that some councils have delayed is that
their monitoring officers like the ones
at essex have been saying this can be
it's an improvement but it can be
improved upon even more
so rather than adopting a code that
might well be revised if we push the lga
to improve it and then we've got to go
back to our members and go through
another adoption process i think some
mmos
just like we we
the mo's in essex wanted to
take the opportunity of
making it even better
so the reason that we delayed as mo's
was we could see
some ways of just improving it and so we
made representations to the lga and i
think other mo's did from other parts of
the country the result was
the the revisions we've now got
so i think now
we're at the stage certainly in essex
we're at a stage where
um
pretty well most of the mo's are
satisfied with the code they think it's
an improvement on the existing one and
we're probably not gonna get any other
changes
and it's going to keep coming back
forwards if you're saying this is like
five or tall that makes a bit
with a proviso it's the final draft
it's the final version
but
the lga have promised that they will
review it every year
now a review doesn't mean a change
but but it's there's potential for a
change so if they do change it then
we'll have to come back again
so could i just i mean for instance we
we are going to put in a small amendment
so then does that you know just be the
devil's advocate do we then notify
somebody and everybody's code of conduct
changes accordingly
no because it's for each council
to
accept the model don't get some model
code of conduct it's not a mandatory
code of conduct it's mandatory that we
have a code under the localism act that
is law
but it's not mandatory what it should
contain so this this is um
a template
but obviously the local government
association are hoping that it will be
accepted lock stock and barrel without
amendment i just i don't know whether
members did read the
picked up the point that
my point about i think there's an
absence of the words or well-being but i
based that on the guidance so
i'm really only adding in what i think
the lga intended
i may have made a mistake and there may
be some good reason for this but i can't
see what the good reason is at the
moment and let's say it doesn't really
fit in with the guidance examples
so
if you look at the paragraph age it's
actually replicated so it should be
repeated in paragraph nine as as you say
so the answer to that question is i mean
that's very helpful from from mrs casey
and
chairman and
i think that answers your question in
that it's for each council to decide
we don't have to report to anybody else
so that seems fairly clear anybody else
ah councillor maze
uh yeah thank you mr chairman um my uh
question really revolves around
whistleblowing
um there's no real mention of
whistleblowing specifically in the code
um
and
my concern is that usually
whistleblowing is as a result of a
confidential conversation with somebody
at some point in doing our work
how does the code either protect us
protect them
and we're not found to be
bringing the the council into disrepute
i'm just a bit concerned that there is
nothing at all that relates to
whistleblowing in in this guidance thank
you
um whistleblowing relates to employees
the whistleblowing legislation and the
policies that we have
uh we already have a whistleblowing
policy for the council
and if an employee
whistle
blue
made a complaint against a member under
this code they will be protected by that
whistleblowing policy which is a
stand-alone policy which covers not only
this code of conduct but it just say
um an employee whistle blew on another
employee they would equally be covered
with with members
as far as members are concerned who make
a complaint
you're you're not
whistle blowing is an employee
um piece of legion is to protect
employees
and it
your democratic elected members you're
here
not in that capacity your
representatives of the public so
this council couldn't discriminate
against you like it could an employee
managers in an organization might be
able to discriminate against an employee
because they complained
maybe i'm rightly complained
whereas there isn't that possibility
amongst members there may be
a dislike of one another
or a sense of
why did you make that complaint against
me but that's not something
that
would be expressly dealt with in the
code what is dealt with in the code
is the member must treat member with
respect
a member must not bully member so in so
far as if a member did make a complaint
and then was picked on
by the
council of concerned that would then be
another grounds for complaint
it's respect bullying intimidation
harassment all those sorts of things
could i could i just come back on that
of course um
it still leads me to some sort of
concern though because often
whistleblowing is usually the result of
conversations not necessarily between
two employees in this situation because
it's it's a little different from a
standard company or business that you
might be working in
um
and
i'm not entirely sure that members could
find themselves somewhat gagged
if there was no mention of um
perhaps wrongdoings that have been going
on bad practices poor practices a whole
range of stuff um that go on
in businesses but just because we are
members doesn't mean to say that we
shouldn't have um the same level
of both support
and protection
um that are afforded to employees
it's a statement as much as a question
but i think there's a question in there
somewhere
yeah
yeah and i think that
i see see the issue that councilman mays
is raising um
[Music]
but
in the case of an employee
um
clearly policies can be brought into
play so that managers
or fellow people in the team do not
discriminate against that person simply
because they've blown the whistle
um
in the case of councillors
i'm not sure what
who would
who would be the person would it be
would it be the leader of the council
that would be
protecting that counsellor but there
again then
then that would be
that's what the code is here for
really
and if
a whistle-blowing member was being
mistreated
abused by other members
then
as i've said that's grounds for
complaint under the code that should
come to the monitoring officer
rather than say somebody else in the
council like a a leader or the chairman
um somehow dealing with this
independently of the code that would in
a sense be sort of bypassing the code
which wouldn't be appropriate so i
didn't i can't although i see the
problem
i can't see a legitimate way around it
you happy with that council amazes that
happy might be going a bit far but yes i
i accept what you're saying and we're
willing to let that one go
um
at the moment okay thank you i'll sit
and listen thank you okay so let's move
along for a little while then thanks to
swain
yes thank you i mean i've got a number
of questions on my own but it's just
would it be helpful if you put the
lights on i'm just thinking i'm just
thinking yeah but the video speed as
well
um um thanks maddie um i
just wonder in relation to that last
point um if a whistleblower doesn't want
to
go to a
manager or a director but goes to a
counsellor um
is there a question there that the
councillor can raise the issue without
identifying a whistleblower
sorry so yeah sorry
would you mind repeating that because we
don't do the lights
if the whistleblower
goes to a counsellor because they don't
want to go through a manager or to it
um
can that can the um whistleblowers
identities still be retained um
although the complaint is actually then
funneled to a
counsellor so you're thinking of a
situation where
where a
an employee is concerned about a
counsellor but they go to a third
council not concerned about council
concerned about their work position oh
right i see what you mean okay
um
[Music]
uh well under the under the officer
member protocol that wouldn't be
appropriate
because the member officer protocol
would say you shouldn't be employees
shouldn't be going to members
about work related issues
so if if a particular employee has a
concern about their terms of conditions
or the way they're treated they should
be going to another employee they should
be going to hr for example they can't
talk to their manager say the manager is
the problem then they need to be going
to human resources
to raise that issue they shouldn't be
using a counsellor to deal with
matters that relate to operational
issues
so i would say that was inappropriate
behavior by the employee
and the counselors should say
sorry to hear that but you need to go
and speak to human resources about this
right can i say that please carry on
absolutely
provide your happy mr quotes to take
these questions i'll do my best i don't
know if council amazed
yeah thank you very much uh council
swain
should the uh that protocol actually be
um one of the incorporated documents in
this uh
uh
code of conduct
uh
the constitu
there's many documents in the
constitution
it's like the local development
framework which is composed of lots of
different documents
and so our constitution is the same has
lots of folders one of those is the code
of conduct
and the member officer protocol would
also be
part of the constitution
so you wouldn't i don't think you would
append it it's it's part of the library
of documents like the procedure rules
for example
for meetings that's part of the
constitution
um
what about cross-referencing it
i think you could cross-reference many
documents
and then it becomes a cumbersome
document
um
and the constitution is available to the
public this would be a part of a library
of documents that are available to the
public
um
i i don't know how if you cross
reference one why haven't you cross
referenced another
and then what have you crossed reference
to another uh and it becomes i think it
becomes a little bit
unmanageable
um
personally
i don't know a chairman whether you want
to to whether the independent person
wants to make any call well i i think
probably the independent person probably
wouldn't want to make any comments on
this i think we have sort of
investigated this unless you would like
to mr mitchell
only as um
that i
i used to be a local authority chief
executive
and would have dealt with
that some sort of issue where a member
of staff has raised a problem
via a member and it's then come to me
it's cumbersome but it worked but it's
not something i would recommend as a
practice because
there can be various motivations why a
counselor would wish to
move a complaint from an officer that
might not always be in the right
interest of the authority
and there are proper processes for
dealing with with staff complaints to
members and
i think they need to be exhausted
before any
alternative approaches made that would
be my comment thank you very much
i'm going to move on to councillor
swain's next question if that's okay
thank you very much
it's the question
um
the way i read it um when a councillor
accepts an appointment
they
have to
sign the um code of conduct
and therefore do not the two go together
and if the
code of conduct is reached significantly
seriously it sort of invalidates the
acceptance of office or position as
council
um
chairman um that you used to under the
old template for accepting
office as a councillor
there was and i agree to abide by
the code of conduct that is no longer a
part as far as i can recall
that is no longer a part of the template
that the government have provided so in
your acceptance of office all you do is
i
fred fred blogs or freda blogs
and you know accept the position of
member for
the particular award
there isn't that phrase sentence in any
longer as far as i'm aware
but
the localism act 2011 is even better
because the localism
says that every council
must have a code of conduct to regulate
member conduct it's mandatory
um
and um within that section is a
requirement that members obviously need
to abide by the code of conduct that's
its purpose
so in a way you don't need
that
extra statement that used to be in the
template because the localism act now
requires members to abide by the code of
conduct it's law
it's legislation
yes um so
every member has to accept the code of
conduct yeah
not in any sense optional
um
but under the localism act you can then
be sort of uh
breaching the localism act if you uh
preach the code of conduct or if you say
you do you don't accept it
the the the localism act says number one
you've got to have a code of conduct
that applies to all members
and if you bridge the code
uh it goes on to say that the local
authority has to have a procedure set up
for investigating complaints
yes so that diverts it through the
yes fine thanks
um
the second is i would do respect to mr
mitchell concerning the um independent
person there are several things here it
um
it says there should be two
and we've gone along with that um i'm
not sure what the reasoning is whether
it is simply to have an alternative or
whether it is desired that you have two
ips
um present to consider um this partly
goes to the question of the role of the
ip
um and i notice um
it is mentioned well somewhere
that
this consideration of changing or adding
to the role of the ip do you have any
um inclination as to how the ip's role
might be
amended
i i have to plead ignorance on that one
chairman and i mean is that a government
consultation document no i don't think
so i um i think it well i can't find it
in here but it refers to
a whole series of possible changes i
don't know if this is the lga ideas or
not i i i haven't read those so i'm i'm
sorry chairman i have to plead ignorance
on that one
yes no no
indication of how it might change
are you ahead of me on that one
councillor swain just like to add um
particularly in this context of this
meeting that we don't have any parish
council representatives i think they are
very important on the jsc and i think we
need to pay
close attention to how we get
to
parish council members onto this
committee it doesn't seem to work very
well the way we do it as a sort of
general circular through the ealc
and in a sense i mean they double up
with the role of the ip to my in my mind
just being sort of
external and also giving um
um
what's to say the view as from
a parish council
and
we probably all know that conduct to
parish councils can be
quite different from the way councils
operate at um
district or county level and so i just
need to pay attention to getting those
councils
um
just to clarify
uh we no longer are if you remember
there was a decision by council
of um about the change to the way
um in our constitution um
we seek nominations of the two parish
representatives on the standards
committee because as you rightly say
counselor swain then there needs to be
two according to our constitution
and we used to
seek to get nominations from the e a l c
but that that proved problematic so now
the new procedure is
that um we need to go out to all parish
and town councils
for nominations
um
should there be none fourth coming
on that first troll
then the district council will go to
molden and burnham town councils that's
really the two bigger councils and ask
in default of nothing coming out from
the first troll
to nominate two
parish council representatives
that is actually what we're doing at
this very moment and mrs casey is
actually in the process of doing that
very following that very procedure so
for statutory annual
it is hoped in may that there will be
two
um parish representatives um that can be
put on to committee so i think that's
very unfortunate and i assume that all
parishes have been
trolled on this one i think it should be
emphasized to them how important it is
for smaller parishes to have a
representation on it
the next one is on best practices it
mentions there about
publishing a statement on how how we
define or what we treat as being in the
public interest
right
um
not quite sure which one that is but
is that something we
should produce so that we
are you referring councillor swain to
the best practice
um appendix are going to appendix one of
your report if you go into that
there is also confusingly appendix c on
the model code of conduct itself
and that gives you the committee on
standards in public life best practice
and one of those is one of the best
practices let me just find it because
you caught me
off guard on that one
um yeah best practice six
councils should publish a clear and
straightforward public interest test
against which allegations are filtered
is that the one you're referring to
okay um you
other members of this committee may
recall that that was produced i think it
was
end of last year or the beginning
of 20 2020 or the beginning of 2021 i'm
not sure this is casey well i'm sure
we'll have
all these matters at our fingertips um
this committee defined a public interest
test
and
that is now a part of the constitution
that's been put into the articles the
complaint procedure
is correct
2021 yeah 22 thank you thank you
yes thank you okay if i go to page 31
there's mention of councillors or
counsellor as being a quasi
employer this is a novel phrase to me
i'm just reading what the importance of
that phrase is
um chairman that's um i think that's in
reference to
potential
quite difficult but
the way that councillors treat employees
can be grounds for unfair dismissal
claim
or constructive dismissal claimed by an
employee in other words if a counselor
is mistreating employees
even though they are not the employer
malden district council is the employee
error in the contract of employment this
case law
that indicates
that bad behavior by members
can result
in constructive dismissal
of employees
and those employees could have a rather
their senior can have a rather large
payout because of it
so i think that's the reference to being
quasi employee
employers in the sense that the conduct
of members towards employees
is very important and there have been
cases in the past where employees have
walked from local authorities because of
badly behaving counsellors
now go to page 33 paragraph four
which talks about improper influence on
fellow counselors in group meetings
um which may be difficult to
demonstrate but it seems to me that that
is uh
um and it it touches on another comment
i made to you when you we've been
talking about you you're asking for
views on this
about the role of
groups and group group leaders in any
disciplinary action
and and i
i made a point that i didn't think that
they should enter into it
um
but
this does seem to rather
um
point the finger as we say uh
undo pressure
um
to vote in particular ways
which which i guess happens quite
frequently
chairman i think the um
yeah
well i think it's it it may be whips um
which will be in the bigger councils um
probably but
um
i think the words are undue
yes
and so it's recognized that if you're in
a group
politics works that we we we know that
from listening to the debate in
parliament about all the issues that
have been coming up in parliament that
you are all familiar with and about the
role of whips
and it's recognized that whips are a
part of
modern and past political life in
british politics
that would also
be the case in in local authorities
maybe less so but still the case so i
think the words are undue
pressure
yes yes
um and how it would actually the surface
um
so if there was a whip
german if there was a whip that was
bullying
um
members and threatening them
with
some benefits they will lose or
we will no longer put we were thinking
of putting you forward to be chairman of
a particular committee and if you don't
vote in this particular way
then
you will lose favor and that's undue
um
my next point i think it's just been
covered by you because you said about
recent case law protecting officers from
uh
um unwelland
comments um so that's their encasement
my last point then is at page 75 it
talks about
um councillors not on a committee
attending
as a member of the public i i'd i've
been led to believe that that was
impossible if a councillor couldn't be a
member of the public
this it depends on the context this is a
difficult area this is a difficult area
i admit that and um
i've not always been clear in my own
minds about my own mind about that i i i
admit that
um
[Music]
and which particular paragraph are you
referring to councillor swain um it's on
page 75 page 75
yeah i'm on page 75.
um
my personal view without i haven't found
the particular paragraph you're
referring to
but
in the code it talks about
you can only if you have an interest
one of those three interests in the new
code of conduct
you you cannot
speak
to that particular item and of course
not vote either
unless
there is a right for a member of the
public to speak
but that's not saying
maybe that's what you're referring to
that's not saying that a member has the
same
can also be a member of the public as
well
that's simply saying that a counselor
shouldn't be put into a
worse position
than a member of the public if they have
an interest
which i think is a different thing might
be quite nuanced but it's different
that is if there is a right in principle
for a member of the public to correct
take part on that not that there
actually is one president yeah for
example in a planning application
members of the public
um in this authority have the right to
to speak to a planning application to
address the committee
um if a member had a
um
if a member
had an interest
then under this new code it's not clear
under the old code but under this new
code it's clear now
that that member
can speak
because the public
speak not because they are a member of
the public
but they are having the equivalent right
as a councillor that can no longer
debate or vote because they have an
interest
if that makes sense
well not entirely absolutely okay i mean
does that does it mean that a councillor
from outside the area
can participate in an area planning
committee um
as a member of the public yes
a councillor from another authority say
a parish councillor
could come to molden district council as
a member of the public
or they could come as a
nominated representative of that paris
council um
to address the committee on a planning
application if we can a member
attend and speak at another area
committee the area that's not where that
council oh i see you remember this
district council oh see i see you i'm
sorry
on an area committee um
no because they're not a member of the
committee
that only see we're talking about we're
talking about here where a member
declares an interest and where a member
declares an interest they can't debate
the issue anymore they can't vote and
they have to leave the room
but if members of the public have the
right to address the committee
that member of the committee that member
of the committee
who otherwise would have been able to
vote and debate debated but can't
because they have an interest
can before they leave the room
have the same say as a member of the
public i say yes if that makes sense
another member
a district councillor from another area
committee
wouldn't have that right because they're
not
they've got no interest to declare that
precludes them debating the issue
yes i think in principle that could
arise but i see the point great uh
councillor swain i i think i'm going to
sort of throw it open to see if anyone
else has any questions um thank goodness
i'm not in your seat
counselor thank you mr chairman you
mentioned group meetings a minute two
ago
um surely they're private and
confidential to that group not anybody
else
and what goes on in that
group meeting is for that group
and not for code of conduct or anything
like that
chairman that's an interesting question
they are
that's true
um
i suppose the question is
in a group meeting are you
acting in the capacity of a counselor
so
um
you're talking about council business
because this code only applied them just
as the old code
so this new code only applies when
you're acting in the capacity of being a
counselor
and if you go to page i'll find it
um
so i'm still familiarizing myself with
this i'm not
the only one i knew where everything was
on this one i don't
um
yeah if you go to page
i'm sorry
page 15.
um
it sets out their application of the
code of conduct
and
as you see here the code of conduct to
an earlier question counselor um swain
you'll see the first paragraph
um code of comment applies to you as
soon as you sign your declaration of
acceptance of office
um
um this code um applies to you when
you're acting your capacity as a
counselor which may include when you
misuse your position as a counselor
or your actions will give the impression
to a reasonable member of the public
with knowledge of the facts that you are
acting as a counsellor
and then it sets out the different forms
of communication that it applies to
um
face-to-face meetings are included so
that will be group meeting
um
now the question is i think um
are you acting in your capacity as a
counselor when you are attending group
meetings
and i have to say that's not a clear-cut
matter and there have been debates on
that point
and
there are better people than me
that have argued that point
and
my personal view
though there are better people than me
who could answer that would be
i don't think they are you i don't think
you are acting in the capacity of a
council but i think it's a close shave
counselor how thank you mr chairman um
surely then you're you're acting as a
member of a political group
rather than a counsellor
and the our counselors are behind you so
you're you are
you're a part of a political group
discussing
matters of counsel but not in a council
setting yeah
um
[Music]
and some people think that that does
engage the code
better people than me
and there are some i've seen who argue
that it doesn't
so
it may be under the new code and maybe
with this guidance which again i'm not
100 familiar with i'm still coming to
terms with it as well
i mean i'm coming here trying to answer
questions but i'm still in the learning
process as well
um
maybe this code there'll be far and this
guidance will enable us to have a
clearer view on that i haven't really
addressed that particular point to be
honest with you i'm speaking from the
point of view of how i view things under
the old code
catalan thank you i come back so that
means
does it mean then that the minutes of
this
group meeting can be made being made
available for jsc
if if they are if the if a councillor is
acting as a person is acting as a
council in a group meeting
and someone makes a complaint
then the monitoring officer has to
investigate
now
the secretary of that group may decline
and say no i'm not giving you the um i'm
secretary of the group i'm not acting as
a counselor in that regard i'm not going
to give you
the minutes
um the monitoring officer would then
have the job of interviewing
different people within that group
without the benefit of the minutes
there is no power in the monitoring
officer it's not like police
um or like um or like a judge
um that has the power to order
disclosure of documents there is no
power of disclosure i i couldn't come to
you if you have a political group
counsellor helm and say i am ordering
you
to disclose your group minutes today
thank you
thank you council at home could i go to
councillor thompson please thank you
it's just a very small matter of
clarification because i heard some
muttering about well you wouldn't be
there if you weren't a counselor in
actual fact that's not quite true it i
can see why it would be thought to be
true of the independence but political
parties
certainly ours and i imagine most um the
local association chairmen are entitled
to attain and they're entitled to attend
so you might well have someone who's a
counselor
somewhere else or
on your own council or not at all so
we do have people come to our
councillors thank you councillor
thompson councillor bill sorry mr i will
come to you in a second
thank you cliff is basically brutally
connected with what councillor helens
asked you
surely if you're for example in a
conservative group or an independent
group
and you're discussing
full council of gender items
then you are
dealing with it as a conservative or an
independent and also as a member of the
council otherwise you won't be
discussing it in the first place
so i think
that's a powerful argument and that's
the argument of those that believe that
the code is engaged
but that's a powerful argument
okay
um can i just go to mr mitchell please
thank you chairman just just a small
point really
in my experience that um
when you do get
ruptions within groups it's very unusual
they finish up in front of the
monitoring officer and they would
normally go through the party system for
any appropriate and i've seen that
happen
um i don't know about independence but
certainly in the three main political
parties i've seen that dealt with
outside the organization completely and
that wouldn't normally be a matter for
this committee to get engaged with thank
you chairman that's helpful actually
because i had a particular case um under
the existing code
and that's exactly the the finding i
made that that is a matter for party
discipline
not a matter for the monitoring officer
thank you uh councillor mayors please
i just wanted to say we should all
behave
politely and respectfully to one another
irrespective
absolutely thank you
peace
councillor swain
just a quick one on that um
yes okay
within a group um but if there is
pressure to vote a particular way is
there not under your influence
it is the question is is the code
engaged and that's the very issue with
debating in a group meeting
um
is the code engaged or not
under the old code i formed the view
that really the independent person has
just
expressed
and
whether that turns out to be the case
under the new code particularly with
this guidance
will be interesting and i'm
i'm going to rely on better people than
me you know their local authorities to
see how they
how they
decide that
if it's not if it's not in the capacity
of being a councillor council swain then
even though it's undue influence
it's not it's not the code that's
engaged that'll be a matter for the
party to deal with
thank you mr crouch um anybody else
oh good
okay um berna how do i move forward now
because we are going to um we have an
amendment don't we which
yes we have an amendment to appendix one
paragraph nine a section a to include
the word well-being and i believe it was
put to the committee
um
earlier via counselor thompson and it
was
seconded
yes it was
that was my understanding so that that
obviously together with the substantive
recommendation now needs to be put to
the committee
i think anything i would say i mean i
agree with what
mrs casey has said
i always agree with mrs casey if so do i
um um
is
that also the it's been proposed and
seconded but it also needs to be voted
on by the committee to become a part of
the substantive motion
yes absolutely yes okay
so do we now
actually vote on that can we do that you
hope personally on whether the amendment
put forward by councillor mrs thompson
actually now forms a part
of the original proposal and if members
here say yes to that then you vote on
that original proposal with the
amendment in it right
great so we share counselor bill
is this relating in any way to what camp
that
forgotten counselling
but mrs actually said
that
he's going to increase his power is that
coming within that or is that that in
the next vote
all right
no no no that i think
yeah no
i don't think we're increasing mr
quilter's power any more than we have to
um
i i think we're just we're just giving
him the sort of the the bandwidth to if
he needs to um he can bring this in
earlier than county council that's all
so based on um
apologies for the interruption chairman
but can i be clear
that the amendment is in relation to
what
the monitoring officer suggested as an
addition to paragraph 9 section a
to include the term the word well-being
as well as financial interests
that is the amendment that we're
discussing because the marching officer
just mentioned there now that it was the
an amendment brought forward by
councillor thompson
i understood the only amendment on the
table was the amendment that the
monetary officer suggested to paragraph
within appendix one paragraph nine
section a to include the word well-being
and i think that's what counselor
thompson actually
okay okay thank you very much just
wanted to charity there wasn't a second
topic that's correct so
it's 33 in the papers right so just to
make sure that i'm absolutely correct
could you read out please berna the new
amended recommendation that we're all
going to vote no no no no no no
no we're just going to take the
amendment first cancer sorry chairman so
if we take the amendment first and vote
on that and the amendment was at page 23
in the papers uh appendix one
that appendix one paragraph nine section
a include the word well-being so a to a
greater extent that it affects the
financial interests and well-being of
the majority of enhancement or
well-being
or well overwhelming sorry
right well being of the majority of
inhabitants of the ward affected by the
decision so we need to focus on that
first thank you very much so councillor
fleming
oh
good job this isn't a bidding thing
you'd have bought it
okay so i we we've all heard what um uh
uh
uh uh burner has told us that so should
we vote on that now please can i take
that vote so all of those agree
so it looks like we're agreeing by a
cent
thank you so that is now passed is that
correct yes jim and that now goes to the
recommendation to full council
thank you very much
and that's all we need to do is that
no no no sorry
and now
now that we need to take the substantive
recommendation
okay thank you so let's take that
substantial recommendation and
we shall vote on that is that correct
has it been proposed
we've done that haven't we no no please
please please tell me
we have we have yes
and so we have all voted on yeah that's
been seconded so can we vote for that
one please
agree thank you
you're a tough gig
thank you very much so are we all clear
on that burn is that all absolutely
correct yes absolutely thank you very
much thank you so um the next item i
have are any other items of business
that the chairman decides are urgent and
i certainly don't have any
um and so i shall now close the meeting
before i do so i would just like to
thank you all for a very very productive
meeting and i must
say a very polite meeting
so i shall now close the meeting
at 15 14. thank you